So how is, uh,
if you can do sort of a big sweeping progress of JavaScript,
how has JavaScript changed over the years in your view from those early 10 days
with a quick add an addition of garbage collection of fixes around security,
how has this evolution that now it's taken over the world.
In this it's been a bumpy ride because the standards body got shut down after
Microsoft, I think, um,
took over the web and then felt punished by the U S V Microsoft antitrust case.
Can you speak to this antibody? Like that was a fun ride too,
because Netscape had, uh,
taken the lead with the web and HTML innovations, like,
um, frames and frame sets tables,
and the W3C was sort of off even then sort of an SGML land heading toward XML
LA LA land. I'm going to be a little harsh on it because it's GML. I'm sorry.
Mel was the precursor markup language to HTML,
or it was sort of the more extensible, um,
generalized markup language. It was, it was a XML like brackets,
but it had all sorts of elaborate syntax for doing, uh, different semantics.
And this is why I think, uh, you know,
TBL and others who wanted to do the semantic web then took XML, um,
forward. But they had this, uh, or some of the many,
we had this strange idea they could replace the with XML or that they would
upgrade the web to be XML. And it couldn't be done. Uh,
worse is better had concrete, meaning the web was very forgiving of HTML,
including sort of minor syntax errors that could be error corrected,
like error correction isn't generally done in programming languages.
Right. That's another amazing thing about HTML is like,
it's more like biology than program.
Yeah, exactly. And so, uh,
XML was in its standard form super strict and could never admit it. You know,
the kind of users who are committing these errors and the funniest part was
Microsoft said, Hey, we're doing XML,
but the way they put it in internet Explorer under the default media type,
put it through the HTML error corrector.
So they kind of bastardized.
It to make it popular and usable and accessible.
And so XML as a pure, um, you know,
thing was never going to take over. Um,
and that'd be three C was kind of not fully functional because Netscape wasn't
cooperating with them. We thought about where to take JavaScript.
And we realized our standards guru Carl cargo realized there was a
European standards body that had already given Microsoft fits by standardizing
parts of the windows three, one API, which European governments and system.
And they said, Microsoft,
we can't use your operating system without some standards. And Microsoft said,
you know, here's our docs. And the government said, no,
we need a European standard.
So this body called the European computer manufacturers association, eczema,
which eventually became global and became a proper noun instead of an acronym.
Right?
So it's just one capital IE now with a lowercase CMA, right?
And as, uh,
one of the early Microsoft guys I met when we first convened a working group to
talk about JavaScript said, it sounds like a skin disease, but it gave.
Uh, I mean, maybe you'll speak to that,
but it gave the name to JavaScript of ECMAScript.
That was the standard name because Java was a trademark of sons.
They were so aggressive.
They were sending cease and desist letters to people whose middle European
heritage meant their PR their surname was vanco and they called their website,
junko.com and someone sent them a letter, say,
you're using JVA at the start of your, the main name. You must cease and desist.
I love marketing more than anything else in this world. Uh, so, so ECMAScript,
and now it was popularly named as E S plus version.
I would say people use jazz more than anything. People still say JavaScript,
JavaScript and all the books.
I mean, when you're referring to it's usually JavaScript.
And when you want to refer to a version of JavaScript,
you'll say [inaudible] yeah.
Yes. Or now they've gone two years,
which is kind of confusing because it's an offset of 2009
[inaudible] yes. 2016.
Yeah. It doesn't match the years that year. Yeah. Yeah. So, so what, uh, what,
what were the choices made and how did JavaScript evolve.
Here? So we, we took this to this new standards body who, which had,
we thought a, sort of a proven record of standing up to Microsoft,
but Microsoft sent a lot of people. They sent some,
some people who were pretty good.
And then when they realized that I was there and Netscape was not going to,
you know, just bend over and do whatever they wanted,
they sent somebody really good. And he was smart guy.
He did a lot of the work on the first draft of the spec. Uh,
Sean Katzenberg he's left Microsoft. He even did what I sort of did.
He told his bosses, I stopped bugging me to do other things I'm focused on this.
Cause it took a lot of focused work to create the first draft of the spec.
And I was still holding. I was spending almost all the plates I had,
like part-time help in certain areas. And on the front end integrations,
I had the front end guys,
but I couldn't take as much time as Sean was to write the draft spec,
but I had to participate because I was essentially helping write down what the
language did and in areas where we didn't like what it did and Microsoft didn't
agree, we sometimes got away with slight changes.
And that's the story of standards.
You have different implementations and depending on their market power,
they inter operate where you have agreement and where they don't,
the dominant one usually sets the defacto standard.
And then you should probably reflect that into the jury standard.
And this happened with JavaScript, uh,
over time as Netscape went down and Microsoft went up,
we did the first edition to the standards, um, codified in 1997 in France.
We had a trip to niece, uh, which was very memorable.
For any interesting reason or just because it's nice.
And, and that most European and IBM and others were, you know, there, uh,
my collage on IBM fellow was a British or, and we, the,
the guy who ran ECMO at the time of Yon venom belt was quite, uh,
a rack on tour on a very fun guy. And he had his house for, you know, the great,
you know, freedom air, the blue bays and this.
Standardization process beautiful or painful that, uh,
those early days you as a designer.
Well, it was painful because it was rushed.
Now guys steel was contributed by sun. So even more than Sean,
you had this giant brain guy steel, helping bringing some of that ski magic.
And he even brought Richard Gabriel for funding.
Richard wrote the fourth clause of the standard,
which was kind of an intro to what JavaScript's all about.
So we had some really good people and we didn't fight too much.
There was some tension where I was fixing bugs and I was late to a meeting.
And Sean Katzenberg at Microsoft was actually Matt, like, where is he?
We need him. And when I got there,
I saw that only he saw this sort of off by one bug in somewhere in the spec.
And then I saw it too. And I said, there's a fence post bug there.
And then we kind of locked eyes and we realized we were on the same page and we
kind of, he wasn't mad anymore.
What were the features that are being like struggled over then debated and
thought about? And.
It was mainly writing down what worked and what we thought should work in the
edge cases that didn't inter operate or that seemed wrong. Uh,
but we were already laying the groundwork for the future additions that I was
already implementing.
I was still trying to lead the standard by using the dominant market power to
write the code that actually shipped.
So the de facto standard would lead the design standard.
And I was putting in the, the missing, you know,
function forms that I didn't have time for in the 10 days.
So this is the engineering mindset versus the theoretician.
So you didn't want to create the perfect language,
but one that was the popular and shipped and all that kind of stuff.
There was, I was standing on the shoulders of giants.
So there was a staged process where I had the whole back things that were well
designed by others in other languages I could imitate,
but I couldn't do them all in the 10 days.
So they came in in 1996 in 97,
and they came into the third edition to the standard,
which was finally finalized in 1999. But at that point,
Netscape had been sold to AOL and was, which was a decent exit considering.
And, uh, you know, had previously been, uh,
mercilessly crushed Netscape was selling the browser along with server software
that it had acquired after its IPO and Microsoft was just underpricing it.
So there was no way to compete with that. Microsoft was also, you know,
making internet Explorer, the default browser in windows,
which is called tying in antitrust law.
And they were doing even more brutal things. There's a famous, uh, investor.
He did very well on Google.
So he's a billionaire rom Shriram and he was sales guy or head of sales at Aetna
escaping.
He got off the phone looking ashen faced after combat called and said,
uh, Microsoft just told us,
they're going to pull our windows license if we shipped Netscape as the default
browser.
Wow, this is so there is some bullying going on.
Material in the infantry. Okay. But,
but JavaScript escaped into the standard setting where there was fairly good
cooperation. Microsoft had a really good guy on it and, you know,
guy steel was there for a time and there was some good work,
but after the antitrust case and, you know,
Netscape kind of dissolving into AOL and not really going anywhere quickly,
Mozilla took years to really bring up, um, the standard froze.
And by 2003,
even though they'd been sort of noodling around with advanced versions
JavaScript too, I I'd given the, to the kingdom to another MIT grad,
Baltimore horror watt, very big brain still at Google.
I think he won the Putnam in 86 and he's very mathematic. Um,
he, he, he designed this successor language JavaScript too, but it,
it only showed up in mutated form in Microsoft asp.net
server side.
And it didn't last there and it showed up in flash and that's what became action
script three.
Action script. Interesting. And then, and then flash was declined.
And so how do we arrive at ESX where it's, it's like,
there's so many where everyone, okay,
there's this history of JavaScript that people were, it was just like, cool.
When you're like having beers to talk crap about JavaScript.
Everyone loves to hate like people who are married say, ah,
marriage sucks is they just want to get, let off some steam,
even though everyone uses the language, but ESX EV it's become this like,
uh, reputable, like it fixed major pain points. I think it added.
Things, the language. And I had something that was already IES five strict mode,
but made it implicit in class bodies and module bodies. It was a big jump,
but it accumulated some of the IES four designs that we'd done with
Adobe,
for what we hoped would be the fourth edition of ECMAScript that were
supposed to fold in some of these old JavaScript two ideas that had come into
actions for three.
So you look at the family tree and you see these forks and the main ones are the
ones that go into Adobe flash acquired from media.
And the one that went into the service side of Microsoft's stack,
which kind of died, um,
and then trying to bring them back into the standard and not quite succeeding,
IES four was mothballed,
but all the good parts that everyone liked made it in ESX. And so that,
that was a success. And I, I said earlier, I had the wrong year.
I think it's 2015. So it's off by four E S yeah,
it was done finalized in 2015. It took a little longer than we hoped. But, um,
cause he has five was 2009 and that was a smaller increment from IES three.
We skipped four again,
we mothballed and we had a split in the committee where some people said,
you know, PS4 is too big. We're going to work on incremental improvements,
no new syntax in particular, they, they promised not quite true, but, uh, they,
they, they added a bunch of interesting API APIs,
Alan where's Brock my coauthor of the hobbled paper.
And he was at Microsoft at the time I ended up hiring Mozilla.
He wanted to get the Mozilla in and keep doing the sort of
editoring entered the job of the JavaScript standard ECMAScript. Um,
and when we got ESX done, it was,
it was a little late 2015 and we switched to year numbers.
So people still call it ESX. I call it ESX. But if you remember, you know,
off by nine plus 2000.